A common request pattern in data
centers today is something called barrier synchronization
whereby a client or an application might have many parallel threads. And no
forward progress can be made until all the responses for those threads are
satisfied. For example, a client might send
a synchronized read with four parallel requests,
but suppose, that the fourth is dropped. At this point, we have a request,
sent at time zero, then we see a response less than a millisecond later,
and at this point, threads one to three complete but TCP may time out on
the fourth. In this case, the link is idle for a very long
time while that fourth connection is timed out. The addition of
more servers in the network induces an overflow of the switch buffer,
causing severe packet loss, and inducing
throughput collapse. One solution to this problem
is to use fine grained TCP retransmission timers, on the order of
microseconds, rather than on the order
of milliseconds. Reducing the retransmission timeout for
TCP, thus improves system throughput. Another way to
reduce the network load is to have the client
acknowledge every other packet rather then every packet. Thus
reducing the overall network load. The basic idea here,
and the premise, is that the timers need
to operate on a granularity that's close to the
round-trip time of the network. In the case of
a data center that's hundreds of microseconds or less.